Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics.
You may have seen an ad before this video,
or maybe there’s one on the twitter feed
you’re scrolling through right now.
Those ads are great examples of how “Big
Data” is used.
They’re often chosen just for you based
on the sites you’ve been to, your sex, approximate
age, where you live and a bunch of other variables.
That data is part of HUGE--GIGANTICALLY HUGE--amount of data about you and everyone else.
Almost everytime you click, or don’t click
an ad, that data gets stored somewhere.
Everytime you watch a YouTube video like this
one, YouTube keeps a record of it.
Even some toothbrushes and water bottles collect
data on your everyday habits.
Data sets include the clicks of everyone who
has ever been on Amazon every like and comment
on every instagram picture every purchase
you make with a credit card every show you
stream on Netflix and how long you watch.
With 7.5 billion people on the planet, lots
of data is created every second.
I mean pretty much just by existing, you’re
creating data.
So much data that we call it…”Big Data.”
INTRO
In the days before smartphones, laptops, and
personal computers, data was hard to come
by.
It took a lot of time and effort to record
measurements, and store them.
Often, data from the United States Census--which
takes place every 10 years--would take almost
10 years to collect and put together.
Computers have helped shorten the time it
takes to collect, summarize, and store data
but as our power to collect and analyze data
increases we just make more and more of it.
The term “Big Data,” in the way we use
it today, is usually credited to John Mashey.
In the 1990s, he used the term to describe
data that is so big and complex, that commonly
used tools to work with data, everything from collecting to interpreting, just can’t handle it.
Your phone records your location, the apps
you use--and how long you use them--and all
those apps that you use are each collecting
their own data on you.
That’s why StubHub won’t stop pinging
me about Taylor Swift concert tickets.
They KNOW me.
The Coca Cola Company collects data from tons
of places, including those soft drink machines
that let you add a variety of additional flavors
to your regular soda of choice.
That’s the reason we now have Cherry Sprite!
Enough people were choosing that combination
and Coke had the data to prove it, so they
put it in cans.
We’ve created an interconnected world that’s
sometimes referred to as the “Internet of
Things”.
Consider the network of “smart” devices
that collect data and can potentially communicate
with each other everything from your refrigerator
to your car to your watch to your lights.
Scientists have even rigged some SPINACH plants
to be able to wirelessly send emails about
their surroundings.
Even when you visit a ski resort, they’re
collecting data.
They may give you a scannable RFID pass, allowing
automated ski lift access.
Plus, the resort employees will know where
you are while you ski.
And an app will give you all kinds of stats,
like how many days you’ve skied and your
vertical distance.
The whole point of Big Data is that there’s
too much of it to wrap our heads around.
So let’s take one tiny aspect of it: Facebook
likes.
For years, those likes seemed pretty useless.
I don’t care if you like The Godfather or
Starbucks or Beyoncé.
Everybody likes those things.
But, that information is more revealing than
you might think.
In 2013, the Proceedings of the National Academy
of Sciences published a study out of the Psychometrics
Centre at Cambridge University.
The participants were around 58,500 Facebook
users who took a personality survey on the
researchers’ app.
Then, they requested permission to view the
users’ “likes.”
They found, “Individual traits and attributes
can be predicted to a high degree of accuracy
based on records of users’ Likes.”
So liking “Thunderstorms,” “Science,”
and “Curly Fries” were signs that someone
was highly intelligent.
Liking “Wu-Tang Clan,” “Shaq,” and
“Being Confused After Waking Up From Naps”
pointed towards someone being a heterosexual
man.
A person’s interest in Hello Kitty led to
a surprisingly detailed prediction.
The paper claimed, “Users who liked the
‘Hello Kitty’ brand tended to be high
on Openness and low on ‘Conscientiousness,’
‘Agreeableness,’ and ‘Emotional Stability.’
They were also more likely to have Democratic
political views and to be of African-American
origin, predominantly Christian, and slightly
below average age.”
This is a tiny piece of the puzzle that can
give you a sense of Big Data in action.
If a little bit of information about a person
can actually reveal a lot, then multiply that
by the tons of other data they’re producing
each day.
Then, that data gets used.
Facebook itself sorts people into categories,
like political views.
In 2016, the New York Times reported, “Even
if you do not like any candidates’ pages,
if most of the people who like the same pages
that you do -- such as Ben and Jerry’s ice
cream -- identify as liberal, then Facebook
might classify you as one, too.”
(That’s just for the U.S., by the way.
We don’t know what they’re gathering about
people’s views in other countries.)
Categories like this allow advertisers on
Facebook to select very specific criteria
and send ads to the exact groups of people
that they want to see them.
For example, a Bloomberg analysis of 2016
U.S. presidential campaign finances noted
that the Trump campaign chose particular groups
of Hillary Clinton supporters to see anti-Clinton
ads on social media, trying to make them less
likely to vote.
Between May and July of 2018, the Planned
Parenthood Federation of America was second
to The Trump Make America Great Again Committee
in Facebook political ad spending in the U.S..
A Planned Parenthood spokesperson told the
New York Times, “Running ads on Facebook
is a targeted and cost-effective way to reach
both our 2.4 million patients and 12 million
supporters.”
They use location targeting, so they can be
specific about their resources in a given
area.
The spokesperson also noted that they run
negative political advertisements about the
Trump-Pence administration.
And the political implications go beyond that.
Another researcher at Cambridge University,
Aleksandr Kogan, used a similar method and
quiz app to that study I mentioned earlier.
That helped the political consulting film
Cambridge Analytica get data on up to 87 million
Facebook users.
There’s a good chance that Big Data has
positively impacted your life.
Perhaps you saved some money on your grocery
bill by using coupons that were tailored to
your shopping habits.
Or you got to buy that Cherry Sprite in a
can.
Big Data is used to personalize medicine,
to predict which baseball players a team should
recruit, and to create driverless cars.
You’re also using Big Data every time you
use Google Maps.
If you have your location enabled on your
phone, information about your location and
speed is constantly being sent back to Google.
That information alone isn’t super useful
to anyone.
BUT, countless people around you are also
using Google Maps.
So, Google has a TON of data about where people
are and how fast they’re moving.
Because they’ve been doing this for a while,
they also know what traffic SHOULD look like
based on things like the day of the week,
what time it is, even holidays.
So, with all their data, they can then tell
you whether there’s a lot of traffic on
a particular road.
In 2013, Google acquired the app Waze, which
gave them even MORE data to work with.
Waze users tell the app when they see traffic
and accidents.
So your Google Maps app uses that, too.
It also keeps track of your personal history,
which is how it can prepare you for your specific
morning commute.
The system City Brain, which was implemented
in Hangzhou, China starting in 2016, takes
this concept one step further.
The goal of City Brain is to minimize traffic
in the city.
And like Google Maps, it’s also run by a
company: a huge retailer called Alibaba.
The difference is: they have the help of local
government as well.
So, the City Brain A-I system gets data in
ways similar to Google Maps.
But, they also have access to information
from the transportation bureau and city surveillance
cameras.
Alibaba claimed they were able to increase
traffic speed by 15% in an area where they
had been given the power to control over 100
intersections.
And it’s a two way street.
(Pause for ungodly amounts of laugher.)
The city also uses their access to this information
to see where accidents have occurred, to get
directions for emergency vehicles, and to
determine areas that need infrastructure changes.
In 2018, it was announced that City Brain
was being implemented in a second city: Kuala
Lumpur, Malaysia.
Of course, I don’t expect you to be unquestionably
psyched about all of this.
I’m not.
Not everyone wants private companies to know
where they are.
And we’re going to talk about privacy concerns
in depth next week.
But let’s move onto another use of Big Data
in the Thought Bubble.
Netflix uses “Big Data” to improve your
entertainment experience.
To give recommendations, Netflix’s algorithm
learns from an endless stream of data on clicks,
watch time, if you like movies starring Matt
Damon.
It might learn that people who watch Queer
Eye, are more likely to enjoy The Great British
Bake Off, and that people who binge watch
tend to like shows with more Seasons available.
It’s also why you might get weirdly specific
category recommendations like “Lovable Losers”
and “TV Shows about Friendship.”
But Netflix doesn’t stop there.
Big Data also influences the image you’ll
see for a show or movie.
For example, here are some of the images you
might be shown for the Netflix show, Stranger
Things.
Netflix uses all the data at its disposal
to decide which image you’ll see.
Since the Title and Image are your first exposure
to the content, choosing a picture that’s
attractive to you can affect your decision
to watch it.
Take, for example, the movie Good Will Hunting.
This post from the Netflix Tech Blog shows
how your past viewing habits can influence
which image you get5.
If you’re an avid romance watcher, you might
be more drawn to a picture of Matt Damon and
Minnie Driver kissing.
But, if you watch a bunch of comedies, Robin
Williams might be enough to convince you to
watch.
You wouldn’t have known he was in the movie
if you had been shown the other image, and
you may never what Ben Affleck’s Boston
accent sounds like.
Just kidding.
He does it in every movie..you’d know.
Using the HUGE amount of data at its disposal
allows Netflix to make YOUR viewing experience
better.
How do you like them apples.
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
And Big Data can do much more than convince
us to watch a movie.
We could be able to better personalize medicines
by sequencing a patient’s genome, and predicting
which medicine will have the fewest side effects.
Or which treatment is least likely to interact
with an existing heart condition.
Big Data is here to stay.
It lets us do things like use machines to
recognize the faces of criminals based on
security footage, or make sure that Amazon
Warehouses are stocked so that you can get
a video game for your niece in time for her
birthday.
And you’re creating it right this second.
YouTube knows you made it to the end of the
video or at least nearly the end.
But the complexity and sheer amount of data
that’s being collected can present some
problems.
In the next episode, we’ll talk about a
few different ways we can overcome or at least
manage some of them.
Thanks for watching, I’ll see you next time.